My instructions tell me
to scrap off 7 stitches.
Instead of using the carriage to knit
a few rows of scrap,
I'll hand knit them and secure the scrap
stitches with an easy-to-remove trick.
Start by pulling out the
required number of needles.
With the tail of the scrap on the right,
manually knit one row.
Next, manually knit a second row.
And finally, manually knit a third row.
Now here's the trick.
We'll leave a loop on the
left side of the work.
I've pulled out a random needle a couple
of inches away from the knitting.
Wrap the working yarn around this needle.
Then break the yarn.
I didn't have a scissors handy,
so I grabbed a letter opener
with a little blade inside.
Next, I'll take each of the pink
stitches off on my latch tool.
A notice that I'm using my finger
to hold each stitch behind the latch,
putting all the stitches on the tool.
Finally, I'll use the hook of the tool
to grab the cut end of the yarn
and pull it through all the stitches.
Notice I've kept that loop on the left.
A when it's time to remove the scrap,
a use the loop to pull the cut end out.
Releasing the stitches and the
scrap can be quickly removed.